more funerals will take place this week
for some of the 26 victims of the church
massacre in Texas for the first time
since last week's shooting we got a look
inside the Sutherland Springs Church the
walls and the ceilings tiles were
replaced and painted white Omar
Villafranca is outside First Baptist
Church in Sutherland Springs with the
tributes Omar good morning good morning
these crosses represent the 26 church
members who were lost just over a week
ago but yesterday hundreds of people
participated in what the church is
calling the largest gathering in its
100-year history all that remains inside
the First Baptist Church is a bright
white room with 26 chairs and 26 roses
the chairs were placed where the victims
were found their names painted on the
memorial in gold hundreds of people from
around the country descended on
Sutherland Springs Sunday to remember
those who were killed rather than choose
darkness as the on young man did that
day I say we choose life pastor Frank
Pomeroy who lost his 14 year old
daughter Annabelle in last week's
shooting led the emotional service I
know everyone who gave their life that
day some of which were my best friends
my daughter and I guarantee you beyond
any shadow of a doubt they are dancing
with Jesus today
and they was Texas Senator John Cornyn
was among those who paid his respects
I wanted to worship with these
remarkable people after the service the
senator discussed his plans to create a
bipartisan bill as early as next week
that would fix background checks this
individual should not have been able to
legally purchase a firearm
there are many convictions in the
military courts and in civilian courts
across the country that are not uploaded
into the background check system the
senator believes had the shooters
history of charges been in the federal
database he wouldn't have been able to
purchase the guns possibly preventing
last week's massacre
my hope is that we can expedite
consideration of this get it into law
and to make sure that this sort of thing
never happens again
the jerk sanctuary will eventually be
torn down and replaced with the memorial
garden but there's no timetable on when
the actual sanctuary will be rebuilt
Gayle all right Thank You Omar